Julian Edelman joining me now on the
Rich Eisen show thanks for joining me
Julian are you doing that I'm doing
great I'm doing great so what is the
mindset of the team right now Julien
heading into Buffalo mindset of the team
is you know focused it's a divisional
game a road game we've already lost on
the road against division opponent and
you know now we've got to go out here
and we gotta take this week to practice
and then try to really take advantage of
it to get better mentally and physically
and go out on the road and try to get a
win especially against a good team it's
it seemed to most that the win on Monday
night against on Sunday night against
Cincinnati that Brady was was taken all
of the conversation about him personally
and that he came out in a way that we
just haven't seen in a while in terms of
his play I mean he's always got that
fire what was what was it like from your
perspective Julian you know I've been
here all that stuff and that's all
pretty much noise around here you know
I've been around Tom for six years now
and he seems to always be on the same
page of how he can you know prepares and
comes out for games every week so you
know he's a good competitive feisty guy
that works his tail off and I think he
just took the same approach and that's
what he's going to be doing what about
sure what about you and him having the
same approach as guys who were not
drafted till much later than perhaps
they had hoped that Brady has always
said that that sixth-round draft status
Stokes the fire within him what about
you
Julian I mean during the year you're
you're really just focused on you know
the week to week activity of you know
your opponent and a games coming in but
you know when you're training and when
you're in the offseason you know that
stuff definitely this is definitely in
the back of your mind and it kind of and
it kind of feels you for how you're
going to train or how you're going to
work and it always reminds you of you
weren't you know that good so you know
it that's all offseason bleed during the
season you're more worried about it just
you know the team's you're playing I'm
going to see whether the week goes by so
fast you're in such a routine you know
Wednesday Thursday you're installing
Friday's mental you just kind of have
this routine and you really don't have
time to think about that you're really
thinking about you know McElveen Gilmore
you know Robbie and you know the
secondary of the Buffalo Bills what are
you thinking of those guys yeah what are
you what are you seeing right now on
film and something that you are
preparing for on Sunday Julian well I
mean they're their team leads the I
think the league in sacks so that could
be due to a really good defensive line
and that kept you do to you know good
coverage so you know we're gonna have to
be prepared to you know beat what we
have to see out there and they're going
to play fundamentally sound football um
they're going to get to the pass rusher
they're going to try to lock you down in
the secondary you know the best thing
that we can do is as a receiver is try
to get open and catch the ball well
Julian I don't know if it's filtered out
to you in New England it probably hasn't
so I'll tell you now i have a three and
a half year old son named cooper by my
older son too but they they wear number
11 Julian and they do it because if they
do it because of you they do it because
it to the point where my son points
anybody wearing number 11 doesn't matter
it could be in basketball and he says
there's Julian Edelman do you think that
could have something to do with your
your play this year Julian I don't know
but that's that's awesome you can tell
your son's that I've always been a rich
eisen saying so I'll take it yes I'm one
option here to rear growing up and you
know when you were on other networks and
doing this and doing that and now you're
doing this so you know that's that's
awesome and I'm that's like an honor
almost you know that's not is there
anything to hear that one little kids
are wearing jersey and contain it's you
and that's it's pretty surreal that's
good yeah man I mean they watch you
catch touchdowns they watch anybody
catch a touchdown wearing number 11 they
watch anybody wearing number 11 shoot a
free throw or swing a baseball bat and
they're like that's Julian they're like
that's Julian Edelman right there so I
think so take that as the wind beneath
your wings sir now it's gonna I'm gonna
hopefully they got me on fantage came so
i can try to go and get some coins or so
i will try to do that form but Julie and
I listen I appreciate you taking the
time out of your schedule to join us on
the show and I'd like to have this as a
regular thing certainly my son's would
definitely like that too that will try
to make that happen thanks for having me
I appreciate it you bet you bet don't
lean Adelman joining me here you bet you
bet that's Julian Edelman joining me
here prior to the patriots taking on the
Buffalo Bills
you